mass-scale front row in the middle
lutheran and is here from Ashland and
Pascal how does it feel to have the
entire confidence supporting you
especially being for the first Cameroon
player and in the first and a finals um
I think is amazing um this shows the the
growth and of the continent Cameroon and
and just basketball in Africa in general
and kind of being at this stage and and
and representing the continent is
amazing me I feel blessed and I just
want the game to continue to grow in
Africa and and and for for kids to see
this and you know hopefully they
inspires them left side midway back
Louis Atzmon Raptors Republic Pascal the
last few rounds there was incredible
length on the floor on you and as help
defenders did it feel like there was
more breathing room in the space in the
paint for you tonight I don't know I'm
not really able to tell but I think for
me is just in transition um kind of kind
of running and whatever basket I can get
easy baskets rim I try to do that so
yeah it's answer your question I don't
really know like if it was a difference
but for me it's just you know taking
whatever defense gives me left-side rash
Pascal rash mandating with sports net
warriors come in they've been through
the finals before there are some people
wondering how would the Raptors handle
the stage how would they handle the
moment how do you think you guys
responded tonight
I think we did you know a pretty pretty
good job at home I mean the fans was
amazing I just want to say that from
from coming out you know if I warm up to
sort of to the end the game that just
the support and then you know going
crazy I never seen anything like that
just you know just happy to be a part of
it and I think for us which is you know
we got we know the team of playing we're
playing an amazing team they're the
champions and and and we just got to be
ready we got to be ready we won Game one
we came out with
you know it was very aggressive on your
own defense and trying to make it tough
foot for the players you know to find
open shots um but you know we know that
it's game 1 and then they're gonna come
out and I'm gonna make adjustments and
we gotta be ready for that into the
middle for throat okay let's go Kayla
great TSN maybe we can chuck it up to
your soccer background but a lot of
speed out there tonight
particularly when you're matching up
against draymond Green what helped free
things up for you I think you know
obviously getting some some easy you
know buckets in transition something I
haven't really been able to do all
playoffs and and I think just being able
to run and and and gain easy passes out
to him and then from there just just
playing just just playing
whatever the defense gives me you know
that's why always I used to I always say
kind of kind of play off of that and and
and whatever his opens is taking them
with confidence and and and and you know
believing in myself right side on the
aisle four rows back
Pascale Eric's under 20 lbs so kanuto
male match this year I can perform out
that under point me collective ma the
quest will appreciate the performance
atony keeps us well response code on
defense and a fair amount Hawaii
Ike Detroit Lakes Rockies all is he a
delayed continue a sponsor and as the
vimana film both Hawaii on da cunha
conversation with each other the gang e
to Lisa the rascal pollen 2 News ESPN
Brasil
did you guys kind of made a make a
concerted effort there to come out
really strong in the second half because
the Warriors have had some like
legendary third quarters here they seem
to really take it up a notch and it
seemed like you guys really like kept
metal to the pedal there
um I think you know obviously it's known
that you know they always come out haves
and and they put pressure on you and and
I think we you know we knew that and and
and I mean obviously tonight and I was
able to stop them but you know we know
that is this a point of emphasis and and
and we know we gotta come out of has you
know in general we got we you know you
can't have slow starts or slow haves
after inside in the aisle to Jackie
Jackie McMullen yes
Pascal I wonder if you can try to put in
perspective for us this incredible
trajectory you are on from when you
joined the NBA and wouldn't even take a
three-pointer to now having the kind of
game you had tonight in on such a big
stage
um I think you know man is it's amazing
and it's just it just proves that you
know if you put the work in and and and
and it's something that is so cliche
most of the time but you know that's as
the story of my life just going out
there every single night working hard to
get to this level and knowing that you
know I have so much to learn and I have
you know so much room to improve and
grow I think that's what makes it fun
and for me just just kind of falling in
love with the game and wanting to get
better and wanting to learn you know
moments like this definitely you know
shows that that you know is I'm gonna
continue to be myself consuming work
hard and and I have you know so much
room to improve right-hand side five
rows back on the edge well if you
pendulum eula to Canada Pascal to canoe
Brahma so to an excellent was M cough
excuse from dick you know at least
ancestors tomasbym akka to summit
Lucilla Simone come come dg2 Jean see
CDC Dupont Circle a difference made on a
conscious Anka do talk to aunt redundant
conscience against all the promises is
the the gaudy mama Montana Mari it
continues reading about the new page
with ho feet response this is an
important form of it last two questions
in the middle five rows back
I'll make um them some lady sport Pascal
phenology come home places among Dwolla
it's good show a pretty much new market
on dew point of another NB Chickamauga
yes you like like some like
response is a fun one busy on a pour moi
ship web of my imagination yoshie-san
Sasha's support Java how my pay
a response to Hamas instead continue I
had to set this unlucky over to lady
Africa actually come on Chrissa [ __ ]
diversion Evo is a possible perfidy to
the the further performance consultant
homage continuity honesty as the economy
may may we see such Shanker yet which
innocently supported to to can consider
here like in Oh God
it's a favor Mon plaisir last question
second row on the left mark Pesce mark
Schwartz ESPN when you were 18 years old
about six years ago had someone told you
that in your very first NBA Finals game
you'd put up 32 points what would you
have said to that person I mean probably
I did was crazy you know at that time I
don't even know if I really dreamed of
you know being at this level you know I
couldn't even think about this this
moment because you know it wasn't ritual
for me but I think once I got to the
point where I felt like I had a chance I
put everything you know forward and and
and I just worked really hard obviously
would help a lot of people you know my
family everyone you know the rapid
organization you know all the guys that
I work out with this summer you know
Rico Hines so many people we just was
just consumed to put the work in and and
you know prepared for times like this
you know I think I when I was 18 years
old I didn't think of it but you know
once I got to to you know believing that
that it was possible and I put
everything that I had to be I just level
you told Doris Burke that this was for
your dad what do you think your dad
would think about how far you've come
I think it's a question that I ask
myself every single day and I know I
wish you know I had I had the answer and
and I know you know people always
usually tell me that I know he's part of
you and you know I kind of wanted to
hear from his mouth and and you know I
think it would be really cool but for me
like I always say man it's bigger than
basketball and and every day every night
that I go out there I have a bigger
purpose and I play for something bigger
than this basketball and and I think
that's what makes it special that every
night I'm out there you know no matter
the result no matter how many points are
scored you know
I'm playing for something bigger than
myself Thank You pesca